alors que le liban fait face à l'une des
pires crises financières du monde depuis
le milieu du 19e siècle selon la banque
mondiale
riad salamé gouverneur de la banque
centrale du pays et proche du clan
alayli est considérée par de nombreux
libanais comme étant à l'origine de
nombreuses malversations financières qui
à leurs yeux on appauvrit le pays au fil
des décennies après une plainte suisses
et françaises lankais du parquet
national financier le pnf s'intéresse
aux très riche patrimoine immobilier du
gouverneur et qui s'élèverait à plus de
50 millions d'euros selon une enquête du
mensuel alternatives économiques
riad salamé homme d'affaires chevronnés
collectionnerait les appartements de
luxe à paris
ces révélations sont à l'origine de la
transposition d'une directive européenne
par le luxembourg en 2019 et qui a
permis de rendre publique l'identité des
bénéficiaires réels de société est
détenue par riad salamé et ses proches
le gouverneur de la banque du liban
possèderait plusieurs appartements et
studios à neuilly sur seine une villa à
antibes et trois restaurants et pour
agrandir son patrimoine réel c'est
l'aimer aurait eu recours au clan
familial
riad salamé bien trop rusé pour avoir
investi en son nom propre
c'est pourquoi il a eu recours à des
sociétés off shore en plaçant des
membres de sa famille à la tête de ces
structures
plusieurs membres de sa famille
apparaîtrait comme actionnaire
secondaires de ces biens mary est salée
mais serait bien l'actionnaire principal
l'homme âgé de 70 ans aurait réparti ses
biens auprès d'au moins sept personnes
de son clan familial huit appartements
serait situé dans le 8e et le 16e
arrondissement paris pour un montant
total qui s'élèverait à 23 millions
d'euros
selon l' enquête d'alternatives
économiques réels salée mais serait
également à la tête de différentes
entreprises et trois d'entre elles sont
pointées du doigt par les enquêtes
judiciaires pour l'achat de plus de 10
millions d'euros de biens immobiliers en
allemagne en belgique et au royaume uni
l'une d'entre elle détient un patrimoine
immobilier valant 14,3 millions d'euros
dont deux appartements situés avenue
georges mandel puis de trois étages de
bureaux au 66 avenue des champs-elysées
selon françois el bacha économiste et
fondateur de libnanews cette plainte n'a
rien de surprenant si on regarde à peu
près les dépêches wikileaks
publié à quelques années quand même on
trouvait déjà les éléments de cette
plainte
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui est
surprenant c'est que c'est une chose au
contraire c'est ce qui est surprenant
c'est qu'on a mis autant de temps à à ce
qu'on puisse sortir ces éléments en
public
le système judiciaire libanais en fin de
compte les gangréné et le procureur
général de la république comme rihanna
d'aimer est un proche de saad arrivé
donc automatiquement ils avaient tous un
t on avec tous intérêts entre guillemets
dans ce système
dans cette nébuleuse à ne pas vraiment à
ce que le système judiciaire libanais ne
puisse pas se mettre en branle en fin de
compte
mary est salée mais ni ces chiffres au
quotidien le monde il explique que ses
avoirs personnels s'élevait à 10,9
millions d'euros lorsqu'il a pris ses
fonctions en 1993 et que son
enrichissement personnel et depuis le
résultat de nombreux investissements
ce sera à la justice française de
tranchées de déterminer avec quel argent
ces biens ont été acquis au pays du
cèdre
cette enquête donne un peu d'espoir mais
le pnf tient à son indépendance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement français et
n'a pas vocation à faire bouger la
situation politique au liban
la france avait annoncé une vague de
sanctions contre les politiques libanais
reste à savoir si ryad salem et figure
sur cette liste
en attendant le liban continue de
sombrer dans l'une des pires crises
économiques et sociales jamais connue
par le pays et la population se
paupérise davantage